(slow music)
- For me, one of the hardest things
about having a friend incarcerated,
is the fact that when I want
to talk to him, I can't.
We're so used to being able to just
snap a picture and text it to somebody,
We can't share that kind of
information with inmates.
(bright music)
I am an artist,
and I'm also the owner and
director of Flip Booked LLC.
When you're serving a sentence,
you miss out on a lot of
the day-to-day activities.
Being able to see a clip of video
of your family and friends
can make a huge difference.
But we can't share that kind
of information with inmates.
The flip books I do take your video
and turn it into something
tangible that you can hold.
Basically, four to six
seconds worth is enough
to make a nice length of flip book.
And when an inmate gets a flip book,
they can see a brief moment
into the lives of the people they love.
You can say a lot in
thirty sheets of flip book.
It’s, it’s really cool.
- I've been incarcerated
in the state of Colorado
for about 13 years.
The hardest part of doing
time is being separated
from the people you care about.
They said they were gonna send me a gift,
and I didn't know what it was gonna be.
And I got a sheet of all
these little pictures,
and then I understood what it was.
This was the first one.
It was a little dog playing in the mud.
Dog joy.
Pure, unadulterated dog joy.
It was a treat, to be able
to sort of get a video.
You know, in a way.
- I think it's easy to understand
why flip books can be so
powerful for the inmates.
But sometimes I feel
like it might almost be
more powerful for the families involved.
Being able to take just a few seconds
to capture some video
that you know is going to end up
in the hands of the person you love
is a very powerful thing.